Chicago in there Chicago was Dennis
Quaid and then I say Michael Chiklis all
Farina all that Vegas oh yeah God you
wrote down oh yes yeah I was talking to
you about the other [ __ ] Vegas this
has been like seven Vegas yeah about the
Vegas with oh my god I never went in for
that [ __ ] show yeah I didn't know
what kind of Vegas it was right here in
a body it was a it was a real it was
based on a movie that mr. Pileggi had
written a million years ago about the
real Ralph lamb and and his interactions
with with organized crime in Vegas in
the early 60s when Vegas was really
starting a really getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and the battles
between outside money coming in from the
mob and old school Nevada ranchers who
that had been their family's land for
years and it was such a ripe world to be
explored but unfortunately that you know
a lot of the executives just we're kind
of looking for it to be kind of like a
crime of the week case the week show it
eventually by Episode six turned into
what it kind of probably should have
been the whole time which was this saga
but by then the audience had gone from
like 17 million almost 18 million that
had premiered to two down
it just it was a de trician and it
couldn't be saved and I felt bad because
mr. pileggi this other guy Greg Walker
who was running it with mr. Pileggi a
really nice guys but it didn't work out
but I made some I got to work with Nick
Pileggi how can I complain you know it's
funny I didn't pleasure I have
Goodfellas on TV for a while I was
supposed to do it as a series
yeah oh I never even heard about them
yeah they came out didn't I couldn't see
he writes every day Nick fudgy every day
he's got stuff going on with Scorsese
he's just he's he's an inspiration I
want to grow up to be mr. Pileggi
he's the best and now you got scorpion
now I got score look at you I'm
forgetting all the well now what is
squawking about scorpion is inspired by
a real-life guy Walter O'Brien it's
inspired by his incredible intellect
he's a 197 IQ average is a hundred you
know if you got a 125 you're pretty
sharp guys guys one
ninety-seven Einstein was 160 so that
shows where this guy is and it's like a
Richter scale so 197 is not 37 points
smarter than Einstein it's about you
know five thousand times smarter than
Einstein and he's he's like a guy he's
from Ireland he lives in LA now and he's
super smart and he does all this crazy
[ __ ] he has this company called scorpion
and he only has geniuses working for him
and they put the problem solve the
problem solved for governments the
Provost problem solve for massive
corporations the problem solve for
charities you know his whole thing is is
I'm I'm a very bright guy there are
other very bright people let's try to do
some good
he also likes to get very rich you know
he's got Ferraris and Lamborghinis
well that's Robert Patrick I saw his on
that he's a commercial yeah he's on the
show he plays their government handler
Elias gable is the is the guy who plays
Walter O'Brien I got called in to play a
guy the plant two lines at a plant yeah
like some furniture a factory or
something hey you've been not doing the
job don't do your best do my best
yeah that's it wait I was just cutting
that episode something like that and you
know what I thought that you know where
that line comes from I can't take credit
for that line don't do your best do my
best
that's Adam Carolla's fake famous line
and he's always saying that line I'm
friends with Adam so I stuck it in there
is a little goose to him but yeah that
that's I didn't even know you came in on
that my didn't I didn't it was I was out
of town oh okay well then I got a
Wednesday and they called in that
morning or something they said can you
make it between 12:00 and 1:00 and I
couldn't make it okay but it was like
1:00 and I didn't know what it was I go
really don't play a [ __ ] factory
where that guy gets shot and killed Yeah
right something happen to your factory
work or some [ __ ] I didn't know what the
yeah he takes a bullet but scorpion is
doing great it's the new number one
drama on CBS it's got a young that you
know everyone wants that young 18 to 49
demographic and normally if you can get
like a 1 a 2 1 9
okay that's now we're doing something
here we're well above a four you know we
were everything we do like a 4.5 4.6
it's at one point it's it's I don't know
it's it's a blessing it's good stuff
right now though it's stuff I'm working
long hours right now but but I guess
very tough right now yeah and TV and you
know what TV is tough but this shows
doing really well and so I'm doing that
and then I got the my first kids book
that's out now I want an alien for
Christmas it's it's it's a chapter book
it's about 134 pages it's for like five
six year olds up to about twelve year
olds you got to read it to a five or
six-year-old seven eight nine year they
can read it themselves but uh I'll tell
you you probably didn't know this mr.
Diaz but on December 17th something
happens with Santa Claus he goes on a
test run he gets in his sleigh with his
head elf Elvis and they do a test run
and they checked weather patterns and
the navigation that he's gonna use in a
week on Christmas Eve to make sure
everything goes smoothly except when he
goes behind the cloud bank in the middle
of the night he smashes with a star
hopper which is like an alien version of
a jet ski
and a little ten-year-old alien was
playing on his star hopper while they
smash that alien flips in the air and
lands in the sleigh santhu Elvis tumble
into the star hopper the reindeer see
the alley and reindeer is stupid they
think they can run away even though
their latch to the sleigh they take off
and crash in a small town called
Millbrook Falls New Hampshire and the
three Bartlett kids find the kid I find
find the alien and realize the aliens
down here Santa's up there we got to
switch them and save Christmas and it's
a really fun it's a fun story for kids
it's already been optioned for a movie
I'm gonna be producing and I'm gonna
write the script and I really really
really if we're really going to get this
movie made need be able to buy it so if
you're incredible listeners want to get
a gift for a kid a niece and nephew a
cousin whatever lets go to Amazon Barnes
and noble.com
I want an alien for Christmas good
family Christmas fun you're an
old-school [ __ ] writer like you
don't give a [ __ ] I'll write anything
books toilet paper right I'll write
anything for this Bazooka Joe comics tie
don't give it just some people just why
just write scripts you know
some people have attitudes or whatever
the [ __ ] you have and I mean even the
genres you know alright Prison Break you
know The Sopranos you like you like the
criminal world I like that stuff but I
also know I've done I wrote a comic book
series for DC called sandstorm which is
a horror movie suddenly a horror story
set in the Afghanistan war and it was
something original idea I had I'll write
anything anything you know why because I
had a job I hated I was in my late 20s
my mid to late 20s and I was like I'm a
young man and I feel like I'm a hundred
years old when I was a lawyer I used to
say to my wife my biggest fear is I'm
gonna be doing this the rest of my life
now that I'm a writer I say to my wife
my biggest fear is that I won't be able
to do this for the rest of my life I
love what I do I'm so happy I get to do
what I do and I like like being
collaborative I love making film
I love producing film I love editing I
mean you were saying Lee that you like I
love editing that's rewriting that's the
best to me it's the second best part the
purest part is sitting there and writing
it and then editing is when you get to
fix all the fuck-ups oh man I over wrote
this let me cut those three lines we can
do that whole speech with a look let's
lose it let's do this let's do that you
know and it's fun and some of these
additives mean they're just artists
they're painters and I get to work with
incredible editors on scorpion and I've
gotten to work with incredible letters
throughout my life I love working with
with great television directors I love
it I'll write anything I'll do anything
let me write your joke right I'll write
you a joke I'll do anything you want
that's amazing that you wrote like a
kids book like a job and you have
children yes I will die two little girls
five and ten Wow like you you are the
the blessing of daughters and they're
beautiful kids they're good kids and you
know I scorpion's the first thing I've
ever done that they can watch now the
five-year-old doesn't watch it cuz she
has just said to me this morning she's
like daddy my kids both because they
grew up in my house they both have me
they've lived in California whole lives
they both have New York accents because
they just learned how to talk in my
house so you know my little one looks at
me and she goes daddy I don't understand
what they're saying I don't I can't
understand the show
I don't like scorpy and I said okay I
like addy you don't have to like it
sweetie that's alright and my oldest
ones like I got crazy it's the best show
on TV because she loves it it's the
first thing I've done that we can enjoy
together family so that's special to me
and the kids book is something that I
wrote for them and they love it because
it reads like a movie I mean it is crazy
there's a guy an airforce cadet that
works at NORAD and he notices when when
the sleigh crashes that there's these
fire streaks in the air and he realizes
that copper when moving at a certain
speed gives off heat flashes and he can
and there's like seven of them and he
connects them and when he connects him
lo and behold it looks just like the
runner of a sleigh and he realizes holy
[ __ ] that's Santa's sleigh because when
this guy in NORAD was ten years old he
was looking up at his sky and with his
telescope and spotted Santa on December
17th Santa cause he's magic this all
makes sense right Santa cuz he's magic
looks at him and gives him a wink
because he knows that he's being watched
and this guy from NORAD goes oh my god
that means I'm special
that means Santa's gonna give me the
best gift on Christmas he's gonna get me
a Commander Cody retrorocket with
optional bonus boosters because I've
been so good and then Christmas morning
he gets a [ __ ] catcher's mitt and he
has had a hard-on for Santa for now his
entire life and now he's 27 and he sees
Santa
crashed into Millbrook Falls New
Hampshire and he's like I'm gonna go get
that [ __ ] so you got the guy from from
NORAD from the Air Force going after
Santa we got a bad shopping mall Santa
like bad Santa like Billy Bob Thornton
realizes there's an alien in town with
these little kids and he's going to
catch that alien and bring him to the
National Enquirer for a million bucks
reward so we got a Santa going after the
alien we got a guy from space going
after Santa we got a school bully
chasing all of them and it just becomes
like a mad mad mad mad world and it
reads like a movie which is probably
hopefully why I got optioned and I hope
we can actually make this [ __ ] thing
because it's fun you're [ __ ] Savage
like I just got a right [ __ ] you gotta
write it and say I am just blown away
after I spoke to you I read a little bit
of Bachchan man I was just I [ __ ]
attorney
why would you quit sucks a big dick it
sucks you know free I knew nothing I did
calm me for all these years and I wrote
jokes and cars and and the years ago I
used to get up about 6 years ago I
started getting up before in the morning
and then that would write for 2 hours
you know get up at 4 4 then what time
would you go to bed didn't matter
I gots got a bad one and I started
writing a blog and I you know forgot
grammar you know it's amazing and how
are you yeah and I'm looking at the blog
after a year and going wow that's what
writing is it's a muscle and you have to
hit it every day yeah that's how I feel
with calmly when I wake up in the
morning I write a little bit and then I
[ __ ] around absorbed and then write a
little more like tonight before it came
I wrote a little more half-hour and this
is and this is you know to put together
sets for shows yeah dad something I've
been thinking about just cuz sometimes
I'll put the sentence out and then work
it in my head yeah then put it on paper
and take a look at okay here we go once
it's on paper it's completely different
and though you can always really hear it
when you say it out loud you're right I
go crazy I write scripts and I like one
of the reasons I like writing scripts
you said grammarly I can't spell for
[ __ ] I mean I can't my spells are for
yeah I know it smells right but my spell
check is like [ __ ] you [ __ ] give
me a break because I can't every of the
work is wrong but the other thing I like
about writing scripts is the dialogue
doesn't matter just have to sound real
bad dialogue almost like it offends me
bad dialogue hurts my ears and the tough
thing with television especially when
you're doing a procedural like scorpion
sometimes you got a right dialogue
that's not that natural but you got to
do all that exposition to explain the
case to the audience the case of the
week whatever it is and and I've gotten
it down now where you can you can give
the audience that medicine but wrap it
up in some sugar so it's not as it's not
as bitter as it normally would be
but I you know all you got to do someone
like you you could write dialogue that
sounds so real that sounds so you know
with all the [ __ ] you've done and all
the all the experiences you had it would
be easy for you you know but but i but
what i do when i when i'm running like
I'll just say it out loud I'll act it
out I'll get up if I'm doing a southern
guy out of my office I'll talk in some
half-ass southern accent I'll start
going crazy idly nice I start sweating I
just got to make sure it makes it sounds
right and you do what you got to do but
yeah I mean getting up and then this
stuff look I meant you know make that in
court like I said he's one of my best
friends I know he's a friend of yours
your friend loved Mick Mick knows my my
I'd give it all up tomorrow to do a half
hour the best thing I ever wrote in my
life is a Curb Your Enthusiasm script
III love Connor
I don't watch our drama the only our
dramas are watching I what I love the
Breaking Bad which I think was one of
the best shows I thought for me it's the
best show ever made I love that show of
that job and but I all I do as I watch
the office and Always Sunny in
Philadelphia Modern Family and Archer
and I watch the stuff I guys wanna make
people laugh you know I hate our
families yeah well some of them are
absolutely [ __ ] I watch him cannot
[ __ ] watch him whatsoever I have a
problem I grew up watching the the other
morning I woke up last
what's the 18th yeah so last Thursday I
woke up early in the morning at 6:00 and
and when they threw my wife out of the
bed so I could write and I brought a cup
of coffee and and I open up the computer
I go to face book I write another thing
it says it's November 13th
Felix was asked to remove himself and
request came from his wife I almost
dropped my cup of coffee you don't know
nobody [ __ ] knows you don't know what
that does nobody knows the tears in my
eyes
the odd couple it's one of the greatest
shows but that's but but that's what I
grew up watching this is what I'm
telling you so you and that I grew up
listening and the family but it was
eleven o'clock Oh Felix 11:30 the
mooners yeah twelve o'clock to Sanford
and Son and 12:30 Twilight Zone opened
up with
10:30 W WPIX WPIX dot 11 yeah I grew up
at 10:30 you had Benny Hill so you were
smoking dog we're playing lifting
Waverly new it 10:25
got to go Benny Hills on 10:30 you went
home just maybe Benny Hill dropped at it
cuz everyone's every once in a while
something would have they'd show at it
something would happen I'm [ __ ] TV and
nobody said nothin there was no wardrobe
malfunction there's no black jumpin up
and down
not that 10:30 [ __ ] and then 11:00 you
switch right over the WPIX honeymooners
and it was the honeymooners and in my
world there was two riders for that show
two riders yeah and he would come over
and break that ball two riders one night
I'm watchin saying that alive I get back
from watching comedy from doing comedy
watching comedy I'm sitting there and
it's Jimmy Fallon and the fat kid that
lost a lot of weight or register or
racial sons and this is when I stopped
this is why I'm the way I am I'm Law
School yeah don't try to run it by me
because I grew up I came from Cuba
yesterday I went to jujitsu and some kid
was there Cuban kid he goes hey man I
brought you a present he just came to
town to visit but he heard the podcast
did with Higa Machado where I spoke
about why I spoke about Dick Van Dyke
Dick Van Dyke is how I learned to speak
this [ __ ] language one right here
from Cuba I know nothing
I knew PS 166 and I knew Dick Van
[ __ ] Dyke all over the fall over but
in season two he walked around yeah
[ __ ] Billy they don't do that [ __ ]
today he skipped already skipped around
and looked at the TV like what [ __ ]
okay that's that's being a [ __ ]
writer okay and so I grew up on that and
then you had on the family that the
mother-in-law with the Desi Arnaz there
was a bunch of shows we grew up but
something that happens when you're nine
in New York you discover the honeymoon
yeah and you know you have to prove for
the other than me and why deal Donald
and when love this bedroom phoned me on
the phone with Bernie Bernie with their
kid Valentin Farrow doing the honeymoon
alliance oh yeah doing the line your
mother going what the [ __ ] is if I'm
gonna sleep while both of my life
because there's no caller ID call
waiting you can use the phone it was
beep-beep-beep and that's what you did I
remember when the GRU
that that was it then the free looks
longer there once was a man his name was
on Felix no it was Oscar asked me good
he wore his suit very messy and see
messy the all that [ __ ] you can't so for
me to watch something now
the bar was ribs jars high the bar was
raised a channel came out recently
channel 20 it's called we TV on whatever
you have you I sit there at night and
sperm comes out of my dick in my
bellybutton
it's a y5o Mission Impossible Canon you
know these are the shows we can run you
know nothing's better than Hawaii five-o
theme song nothing no to me Mission
Impossible okay yeah I'm yeah Mongo's
flopped the cowbell bongos came before
the [ __ ] cowbell that whatever
talked about I hit them had babysitter
in the head one makers like that I made
them a Wi-Fi vote that that that I hit
her with the shoehorn what was the name
bill so she used to shake when she
talked my mother said she had syphilis
so I hit her in the head with the
shoehorning [ __ ] I was like seven hahaha
she was still alive whenever I go to
Union City she'd still be shaking you
didn't mean that what if you want the
Wi-Fi though but I grew up on the
honeymooners and there's times that I'm
not doing nothing guys I'm not ashamed
to admit this I'm not doing I have 16
episodes on my TV on DVR yeah now when
nothing's going on I sit there and I put
them on and I start calling oh yeah
eyeballing the lines [ __ ] balling
yeah I'm not I watched the 1-1 he
[ __ ] tells the magazine company he's
gonna die cuz he read the dog oh yeah oh
my god and he shows up with Norton
dressed as a [ __ ] doctor and he's dr.
Norton to keep it easy Norton walks in
don't touch me I'm sterile where's the
whole thing don't touch me I'm sterile
more would you knock it off I'm still
not unless I'm we're gonna give the guy
the checking when I get the [ __ ] out of
here all right that comes in who's this
this dr. Norton we want to give you back
to check we discovered I don't have
arterial mana chromium right
Oh remember that
don't have arterial monochrome Ian I'm
gonna give you the check and we're gonna
leave now wait a minute come back here
and he tells him you know I truly amount
of Crawley and who was this guy he goes
this don't you see that we have a human
interest story here and he goes dr.
Newton how about we take some pictures
and do a story about and Ralph goes no
not really
he's busy he's gotta go back some and
nothing looks like this I don't mind a
couple pictures
okay what what Carney did on that show
was meh it was a master's class come on
dog come on though hello Bob or stringer
palapa knees finger Paulo when he [ __ ]
danced here's a dance you should know
the ha ha ha
and when [ __ ] Carlos that was the
first Puerto Rican ever on TV and he
told them you know I don't care Oh mrs.
mrs. McNally upstairs manicotti he wants
to do the Mambo everybody every and you
and your age should be ashamed of this
the episode when he throws his
mother-in-law that's one of the most
there's two episodes that I look at
today and I look at because of their
brilliance and it always involved the
mother-in-law just 60 seconds I give you
two minutes and she'll [ __ ] ruin my
night and he sets the time and he's got
tickets for the play yeah murder strikes
out murders Jesse you saw Jimmy Piersall
Boston Red Sox lost his mind he lost his
[ __ ] mind murder climbing up climbing
the back style a real Boston [ __ ]
Rebs I used to run around the bases
backwards that they hit a home run and
[ __ ] he's crazy Joe sanded people and he
goes you know it that the press tells
you not to tell their story and at the
end he goes she goes and all the press
saying that not to tell the story it was
the butler Billy and awesome the bell
goes well it was perfectly good alarm
clock it was the timing was pertaining
was perfect I'm off so he goes he hits
it and he goes you well that was going
anywhere whether you were going any way
or any other way I'm still throwing you
out that
and the loan when they found the
suitcase filled with money that's one of
the best written TV episodes you know
what one killed me the one that killing
me made me cry killed me not did not cry
because funny when they adopted the baby
and had to give it back I never saw them
that's the 1951 one yeah there's some
one of the lost ones and any any and he
kept saying about the baby
the month they adopted a baby they
finally had a baby
and he's so proud and Alice is so happy
and then the mother who gave birth to
the baby decided I can't do this I need
my baby back and Alice is like Ralph if
we love her this much imagine how much
she loves her and he and he and the end
been crammed ins pacing back and forth
he's like I don't care it's my baby I'm
in love with her I'm in love with her
you can't she can't have her back it's
my kid I don't know I'm in love with her
and he's just going over and over and
it's heartbreaking and they give the
baby back it's like a dramatic
Honeymooners it'll kill you and that's
the one that always stuck with me to me
he's always been one of the best and you
said Morton Carney was a master
violinist that's the thing that I
realized when I started I was you know
kid and I was may know an elementary
school or late elementary school and I
started watching it and it was when my
dad on a you know on a construction site
someone showed up one day you know
selling TV radio combos that fell off
the back of a truck and he came home and
I mean when I say the screen was this
big there's like two decks of cards on
top of each other and it was this big
and then there was a little radio next
to it and he got have like 10 bucks 20
bucks he gave it to me I I thought I had
the world and I put it on the little
desk next to my bed and I'd lie on my
side and I'd watch this little
black-and-white screen every night
supposed to be in bed but I had to watch
The Honeymooners I had to watch The Odd
Couple and it's it to this day even when
I write drama everything or it has to
have humor in it because that's what I
loved and I remember watching The
Honeymooners
and having this epiphany of oh my god
all the [ __ ] I've been watching that
hasn't been doing it right has been
stealing all the [ __ ] all the jokes the
pratfalls the moves that I saw on
Three's Company in 1977
whenever the hell I saw it it was all
stolen from the honeymooners they just
did it badly oh the crazy that mean he's
the original crazy next-door neighbor
he's the first Kramer you know all that
[ __ ] and the honeymoon has just laid the
platform the blueprint for everybody and
everyone's tried no one's gotten it and
it's just you watch it and it's it to
this day it's one room one room an
icebox the size of a shoebox one window
one door and a and God bless him a chest
of drawers that seemed to have
everything they needed in those drawers
I mean anything ever needed a pad and a
pen was in there an extra shirt was in
there you know if they needed a deck of
cards and a pair of dice everything was
in the and that's it and a table with a
couple of chairs I mean that was it and
and they made masterful storytelling
weekend week out yeah I love that show
the Christmas episode mean that the the
[ __ ] food with the chef of the future
when they were gonna cut the slices
future future chef in the future who is
Fe can acquire Apple Koenig I mean just
[ __ ] that we still [ __ ] around with
people the tax one is just but the one
who was the guy when they're at the pool
hall and that my friend was my friend
hog my friend huh is even bigger than me
I got a friend Shirley how you feeling
I'm pretty high you see I gave you a
nice little edible look at that look at
the shape there
look at me so happy you wanna give me
mushrooms too he's sitting there
thinking he's like when is this guy
gonna shut the [ __ ] up no this is what
we do know I know this is amazing imma
tase him
if what we do on this show I got a
second chance in a lot of ways and you
are the [ __ ] epitome of stories for
this this is this is no we do not take
very cast you know
people email every week that they're
unhappy they don't know what the [ __ ]
do we you know when you tell you a story
everybody goes through this everyone
with some people that have the balls to
do what you did or not even balls or
this people were just scared and they'll
live their life to the fifty in one day
you know you weren't scared and it gets
well I I had to do something but I tell
anyone like when people get the press to
say guy was deprived you should say it
gets it'll get better
you gotta just push through it you got
better yeah you sit down take the
windfall that's what's gonna happen but
if you get up and do something about
what you it's a beautiful story
you know you've been writing all these
[ __ ] stories write a [ __ ] story by
yourself that's what you gotta do I'm
gonna bite yourself we got all this [ __ ]
with [ __ ] washing Joey vida Stefano
Joe Wando Tommy Easter James Malawi
whatever your [ __ ] name is Albert
Jimenez you always got throw a porter
Regan in there
Michelle Clifford I love you dirty [ __ ]
Amanda Taylor I love you too thank you
for torture and lead today
Roz dude stay black and maddisyn-rae you
sexy [ __ ] I love you too
mix ain't always been a [ __ ] trip
really what do you have to say about
this yeah I actually had a question for
both of you guys how do you guys deal
with like Nick like you you loved all
the shows you worked on and like not all
of them I just won't tell you what you
want well what is it like one thing I
can't believe was it one like a job like
that end the one that hurt was Breakout
Kings is that show was the highest
testing pilot FBC Fox Network had had in
a over decade tested through the roof
and they picked up two shows that tested
substantially lower than we did one show
got cancelled after two episodes and the
only reason to get canceled after one
episode is because it got canceled after
one episode they would look like total
[ __ ] idiots so it got canceled after
two episodes the other show got canceled
after 13 episodes our show got picked up
by A&E which never happens you never
have one network say well we're
development execs it's our job to
develop TV ourselves and we're going to
to our corporate bosses that these other
people did a better job than we did and
we should buy their castoffs
I mean it's career suicide but they love
the pilot so much and it tested so I a
and he took it and it preceded them and
set the record for the highest debut at
AAA it ran for two seasons with with Dom
Lombardo Z and that was around the time
like American Horror Story started
getting popular and the people at A&E
said you know what we got to go Shan
rrah
we got to go Shan R we got to move away
from cops and crime in the meantime
Breakout Kings if you watch it watch the
first just watch the pilot it's the
funniest one our cop show you'll ever
watch we cast Jimmy Simpson who's watch
house of cards
yeah he's the hacker on house of cards
okay he's one of the best actors in the
country
he's like a hidden gem and I cast him
off of Always Sunny in Philadelphia a
comedy not to be in this hour cop show i
Sony's I think that's a groundbreaking
comedy you might like I know you don't
you like the old-school stuff but you
might like cuz these kids on Sonny I've
heard that it's they take chances they
do different things and it's and it's
wild and they the the the whole thing
with with Breakout Kings is they decided
we're gonna go John rrah and so after
the second season they just didn't have
us come back and we left at the end we
ended the second season on a massive
cliffhanger never got resolved that one
hurt because that show was was my voice
it was what I loved and it was fun and I
loved the actors and I loved going to
work that one stung
that was tough um but then I then you
know you put it in perspective and say
you know what that sucks
I lost something that I that mean a lot
of other people worked hard on but you
know what I'm healthy I've got a family
that loves me I love them I got a box
full of pens I got a box full of fungus
I've got a full four and a half inch
dick life is life is [ __ ] good that's
fully erect Lee
it's I just get a text from Betancourt
you're killing it yeah yes great [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you uh you know I don't know I may tell
you that I remember I [ __ ] going to
an audition
the week before Christmas going down to
the little [ __ ] Olympic going into a
room and reading and her gone come back
in two hours
I go back in two hours when I get back
into I wasn't Travolta's there I know
you were Travolta and he's giggling and
we're all giggling she comes go listen
come back tomorrow 11:30 and you're
gonna read for the director okay and I'm
washing my [ __ ] I'm putting my warm-up
suit on I'm not gonna call that the
director hide somebody on in New York
the night before that happens it happens
it happens in some way and it's how you
I used to always get cliff tanked I'm
Captain December I started rocking now
yeah I'm already ready I'm like next
week
that's it my comedy career ends on
Sunday and I go to podcasting and films
till December 20 yeah that's all I do
now and it's a it's it's it's every year
it just gets hot but every year I go on
for something huge and I going on the
20th for it and I got to sit for three
weeks during the holidays we wait live
wing and then they call you I'm the
fourth and they go either they went with
year they went with somebody else you
made me wait for [ __ ] three weeks
something you know they work during
Christmas you know you nobody just sits
there and opens up [ __ ] presents so
it's there's been all those situations
but does I've also been on the other
side of the coin yeah I also know what
it is to go in and get it right away you
know couple years if I got a call at
1:00 in the afternoon Joey they're
looking for somebody on Ivar for an
Italian sprint commercial [ __ ] walk
when can you walk to an audition yes
when can you [ __ ] walk to an audition
I walked went in red
walked out the next day they had
callbacks I didn't get called back I was
depressed they gave me the [ __ ]
commercial three days later yeah I made
a ton of [ __ ] a little I walked to a
commercial how many times that happens
never yeah is it weird thing on that
side like do you are you involved with
auditions yeah I've been working with
him for three years like here oh I
didn't do this well I didn't like
I don't like though I did it orjust
that's the worst part of the process ly
be honest the worst part of the process
for me the thing I liked the least about
my job is casting for a couple of
reasons one thirty people come in the
door every single one of them is
talented you don't get into that stage
of the auditioning process unless you're
talented unless you're immensely
talented and there's only one job got a
twenty nine thirtieth twenty nine
nothing a twenty nine thirty eighth
Chancellor Zeng when you go in to it's
not at the end of the day my final call
I might be a showrunner on a show but
there's networks people there's studio
people there's a million people that are
involved in you know you have a very
strong voice but you don't always get to
make the final call and I hate seeing P
and sometimes someone will come in and
just kill it
crush it they were amazing but you're
not mmm they're four inches taller than
the male lead and we need someone
shorter than the male even the male
leads only five foot eight so we need to
get a woman five foot six or smaller and
you had a woman who came in it was you
know 511 and she was amazing but you
can't make the leading man look tiny and
that's the note you get from the studio
and there's a million reasons why an
actor doesn't get a role the last reason
on the list is it which never comes into
play is you're not talented it's always
the wrong look the wrong this the wrong
map but it's never oh my god your read
was awful everyone comes they do it a
million different ways and they're all
interesting they're all good you want to
give 30 jobs to 30 people that's the
part I don't like yeah and it's cuz I do
that I audition all the time I run
around town with my little [ __ ]
knapsack full of stupid stories ago hey
you want to so it's just it's
auditioning every time i pitch a story
i'm auditioning right and the worst part
of anything like that like even job
interviews is not like they don't call
you usually when you don't get a job so
like and it's like it's just awful not
knowing like do you ever call an actor
be like listen you did a good job at
just the network said no or I just no I
actually have done that
it's rare but I've called their agents
and I said I just want you to know your
client didn't get this job but they
crushed it and I want to keep them in
mind for other stuff they were perfect
it was this thing it was that thing they
want to go a little older they want to
go a little younger
they now now this do you came in and
said they want the guy to be black and
you know you could be as good as active
as you are all of it but you can't be
black that's the worse that happens a
lot okay you just everyone just heard it
Joey just said black people the worst oh
no no no it wasn't that I've had three
or four situation too early on when I
was learning to be an actor when I had a
manager was very aggressive and there
was one job in particular that they
probably saw me four times in five days
and then said that they switched the
character the boy or the other way
around I know black people have been in
for two weeks mind breaking pile and
they switch it to a white guy it just
happen make it like that yeah it just
happens no way you said what you said
you don't like black people I don't I
don't like when I go in for an audition
at first and they ask me how tall are
you what do you weigh that's it I don't
like that that's pre qualifying you
you're done you know they just asked you
to kill you don't even know what the
[ __ ] to say and who the [ __ ] cares come
in and become the character I don't give
a [ __ ] if you don't that's why you
saying that I can't go in to play
opposite Tom Cruise if he's five [ __ ]
six you follow me you know I know
somebody who did the movie but the music
down in Miami
he was just double oh the rock of ages'
it body double he was telling me it's
amazing [ __ ] tiny the guy was I was
skinny you know the whole [ __ ] thing
so I always knew I'd never taken
I've never taken an acting decision
poorly it's always gone through me i
digested it and I moved on I've always
been I've had friends that have never
been suicidal some things some things
I'll go [ __ ] I should have done better
in the audition my eyes ago
right and you're 44 it's over it's nuts
I tell you something
44 the past four or five months I said
to my wife I'm like I'm getting
headaches and like and at night I'm
lying in bed next to my daughter reading
to her and I'm holding the books 44 I
got to get glasses right for you have
glasses everywhere everywhere you don't
go to a doctor because the doctors on us
it's three four hundred sag with the
whole thing you don't need that just go
to Costco and get the 20-pack the
[ __ ] vision and just put them in
these magnifiers put them in your car at
the bathroom because you're gonna start
the kitchen anyway we gotta look at [ __ ]
cuz it just goes it's cry wait it's
[ __ ] crazy
I've never worn glasses in my life never
[ __ ] eagle-eye never I can see a coke
rock under the [ __ ] carpet that's we
help people for years and I [ __ ] once
I stopped doing blow and stopped at 40
for my eyesight went into the [ __ ]
and now so now I am at home I got the
glasses on I'm doing the audition room
with a book with a book but I get up I
write it once you get in the room I'm
the king of improvise yeah but once I
take those glasses off it disappears
yeah and when you're in front of five
people it disappears I don't care if you
did it eighty times you gotta look down
for key words it becomes yeah you're
[ __ ]
there's no mobsters with [ __ ] glasses
yeah so I could do a great way with
glass and maybe get contacts man I came
for one eye he told me already
cuz you gonna be like a [ __ ] schmuck
it's for one eye the left eye went down
the tube that's why if you look at my
car got bent on the left so put on what
do you want to put in one contacts a
nightmare and if you haven't done it all
your life you're just not gonna [ __ ]
go home one day I know I can I can so
it's it's I got to do something
different for auditions now it's become
a problem yeah that I do a good one but
it's not me it's not me I gotta learn it
inside now but I never really sweat it
if I want some I always went for it yeah
that's how I get my [ __ ] if I want
something I go for it if you put out a
breakdown of you tell 20 people I'm
gonna for this guy and I find out about
I'll get the script I'll call my buddy
at CAA will get this grit and I'll put
it [ __ ] that's how I got the longest
shot yeah they told me they want a big
[ __ ] or Siragusa
yeah I thought one thing to myself
they're stars
you gave him goose' [ __ ] I get a goose
a [ __ ] they're stars but they're not
funny
right not what I I'm a classically
trained like I'm training in front of a
deli in Jersey that's classically when
you when you can hold court dolly would
hate other [ __ ] funny people yeah
that's classically trained then there's
a stand-up I did comedy in Buffalo once
you go to Buffalo that said it's over
Buffalo they'll shoot you you're good to
go so I knew that in my heart
yeah Nick and I put an audition tape
when I said it to him Sam and I got the
[ __ ] row spider-man two same [ __ ]
thing well was the one where you pulled
your pants down when they were turned
around American family the pilot before
this one on ABC years ago by the family
that wanted to move and they moved and
they took they were moving the paradise
and they had me for a [ __ ] neighbor
never got picked up I still bump into
the people they're like listen again
yeah that pilot that yeah I bump I kept
one that was the first pilot ever that I
shot that people kept in touch of me
yeah I did that one in Bronx County it
was a pile on CBS 15 it was gonna be
there answered an NYPD Blue right and
these guys really kept in touch with me
because the pilot had I forget I could
drop a bunch of names I forget who was
in this pilot but they had this show
covered like this show was funny as [ __ ]
scored the highest of ABC ABC didn't
pick it up they picked up three other
comedies and they all shouldn't all that
[ __ ] but yeah it's the story of life you
don't know why they do it today I was
sitting there today we got to get out of
here the minute yeah just want to tell
you something I'm sorry to keep it no I
don't want to sitting there today and
part though I'm going to acupuncture and
I look up I don't look at [ __ ]
billboards again I can't see but I'm at
that light I could see the billboard
Dracula whatever let me ask you a
question how many [ __ ] Dracula movies
can they make how many spider-man's are
we gonna [ __ ] make them till when are
we gonna keep me
he got bit by a spider now he thinks
he's a [ __ ] spider his grandmother's
[ __ ] they killed my father and you
move on with your [ __ ] life
that's it there's only one way you could
tell the three little [ __ ] pigs not
these [ __ ] people so I like I tell my
agents like oh these are the smartest
dumbest [ __ ] people you've ever met
in your life when we makes a decision he
makes a decision on his own when I make
a decision I asked my wife you asked you
have also god bless you your wife
because if you wouldn't have a wife they
have a cliche saying behind every good
man there's a good woman it's another
cliche I'm living proof you just you
know there's most women you go home to
and say I want to be a riderless if she
was abroad from stats my own [ __ ] you
said you went home and she said I want
to be a writer I'm thinking of a career
well you have to do that on your own
because I'm not leaving yeah that's what
you're a lawyer you're a lawyer go make
some more gonna make money go slip and
fall and sue yourself let me do some
shots
I love to have you on at broke now
what's the name of the book and give
them a welcome now we could put this up
I want an alien for Christmas go to
amazon.com go to Barnes and noble.com
great gift for a kid and if it says on
Amazon temporarily sold out it just cuz
we're selling a lot of them [ __ ] that
still order it they'll get it to you
because we're getting a bunch shipped
over soon I want an alien for Christmas
and thank you for having me I'd love to
come back let's come let me come with
Mick and we'll get real stupid I'm crazy
I was low for two seven [ __ ] hours
seven hours [ __ ] out of here Arnott calm
it's not about vitamins and whatever
it's about a higher level taking it your
[ __ ] body in your mind to a higher
level it starts with alpha brain I'm not
gonna tell you again you having problems
your confusion now focusing 100%
money-back guarantee we don't even want
the [ __ ] product back what does that
tell you when you wanna Chinese
restaurant got pork fried rice let's say
they throw a [ __ ] cattail in there
and you bring it back into the give me
back [ __ ] no you get that they'll take
it out and throw it and tell you they're
gonna give you in the water they just
remake some soy sauce and give it back
to you not they give you a check back
I'm trying to say is Allah don't [ __ ]
around all right go to Allah Tom see
what they got the vitamins nutrition
they also have weights I can't help you
with that supper on them
vitamins and minerals give you 10% off
go down and press what in the box Church
stop it Church get 10% off also looking
for the stay on a program like dollar
shaper they say right to your [ __ ]
house every month you have to leave the
goddamn house me and these calm how long
do you have those disgusting [ __ ]
underwear on with skid marks and blood
and [ __ ] chlamydia lotions on it you
don't need that [ __ ] you know how long a
man holds on to underwear seven [ __ ]
knees and he keeps the chicks on their
way to after you break up with them you
take the little on these home you sniff
the [ __ ] out of the middle and your
whack ball off for [ __ ] years till
the thing they leave it's not like [ __ ]
no more you could smell the cotton the
[ __ ] hand was picked with whatever
the [ __ ] it is right so I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm saying but I'm trying
to say to use me on these heads
tremendous selection go to me undies see
what they got women's and men's go to me
on these calm and prescient Joey boom I
got me on these on right now my balls a
[ __ ] tremendous I use them to work
out cause it keeps everything in place
your nut doesn't pop out at the gym plus
it pulls the moisture out of your
nutsack so it goes into the - well - God
my balls don't sweat at all it's your
mother smiling Irish bring me on these
compressing Joey boom and then you're
gonna get 10% off 20% 20% off [ __ ] the
Jews and free shipping the free shipping
in the US and Canada who's gonna give
you that type of action my brothers I
love these guys Iron Dragon TV I was
watching it today I didn't watch any of
the movies I just want to see how it
worked
this is the [ __ ] future this is
nanotech laying it down for you [ __ ]
they sponsor fighters this iron dragon
tv.com you press them what Joey or
Church and you get two free movies to
start off and on your Roku they're gonna
have fun things on Saturdays I'm not
allowed to tell you listen they got
classic martial art think I hit man
series they got the [ __ ] a life of a
ninja they got Donnie Yen they got chow
yun-fat they don't have Bruce Lee [ __ ]
like the way you line the people they
may have Bruce Lee with the 1e
I'm sorry remember when they had like 20
- Bruce Lee's you know the Chinese there
they're all cousins - [ __ ] iron dragon
TV Donna Yang Chow Yuen fat go to iron
dragon TV right now do me a favor
everybody here's a martial artist we all
love that old classic [ __ ] press
somewhat Joey orchard boom and you get
two free movies who's better than
[ __ ] you [ __ ] alright when I'm
putting this out the light there's
they want us to hope you enjoyed it
Nikki yes who's better than you the best
story on Hollywood now you guys have
been taught me this [ __ ] with all these
suicide kings it's all over when we
leave here I'm calling you Monday we're
writing your story I'm gonna play one of
the guys suicide walls I'm gonna play
one of the guys that slips and falls Lee
what's up with you [ __ ]
you selling shirts you got the block we
lost 70 pounds he's been walking are you
serious yeah that is Finn that's
fantastic
I put on 25 pounds since the pilot so
you're working in it I never that's
that's what killed me I was always a bit
like that but like when I went to school
in Boston I walked around I came out
here stop dating the Mexican woman
knocking Jew you guys got the worst
[ __ ] died in the world so you started
dating the Mexican chicken you went
bananas yeah of course you start eating
[ __ ] and then she Ladas and you
couldn't [ __ ] stop okay
ant your [ __ ] and your puss not bad
what happened this guy's little filthy
Jew you know these shoes they try to be
all right about jewish chicks but one
taken around of Puerto Rico no [ __ ]
young broad they lose the [ __ ] I did
not know that about the Jewish beat yeah
my girl from before this man was black
he's a freak these Jews of heaven you
never never dated a Jewish girl for what
no I don't think so no I've dated many
Jewish girls one like the lovely pale of
another I loved wonderful Jews don't
like it's like me I'm CUBAN I would
never do the Cuban chick they drive me
crazy
see I'm Italian I married a beautiful
time could you really almost done
copacetic right here no I mean when I
wanted have red hair you have right here
I always Auburn it when I was actually
quite delightful to look at thank you
very much thank you sir you got balls of
steel
yeah something a lot of people forgot in
this [ __ ] country thank you know your
success does not surprise me it's balls
brother I had a lot of good fortune but
thank you for having me on
stay black do you gots brothers coming
up next Lisa at get it together we're
gonna Comedy Store what are we doing
okay let's go we gotta go on five
minutes so get it together I love you
guys stay black put that mean what's the
music uh we're playing the Beatles but I
have to read the ants first right take
your time but ever yeah
she was brought to you by honor calm
music over Church to get 10% off of any
of the great products like alpha brain
New Moon
Suntech immune from to export shows also
brought to you by naturebox.com/tyler
box oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] major box why
you sitting there like a [ __ ] Mook on
the other side
stop going to your wedding to the lunch
thing I work with that glass with all
those potato chips and saturated fat you
don't need that [ __ ] go to nature
box.com you know why cuz everything is
free of nature bugs that's how we're
doing it today free [ __ ] free you're
saying Joe how's it gonna be free they
don't send you five packages of
nutritious snacks whether it's a
chocolate bonbons whether it's the
[ __ ] pepper and salt or lentil beans
I mean everything is delicious
nutritious and everything is good for
you you're not gonna blow them be a fat
[ __ ] go to naturebox.com/tyler right now
I'm pressing Joey boom and we know
you're gonna get a free box sent right
to your [ __ ] house no drama no
nothing I'm telling you right now you
gotta enjoy it every damn Twitter people
thank me it's a joy thank you for the
code for nature's box I've been eating a
cheese box for years I [ __ ] love it
what's the code Joey
mmmm what you got a free sample of box
sent right to your door
gratis free go right now right now don't
[ __ ] around I love you stay black like
you just heard this now that the show's
over don't forget to go to nature box
calm and sound out to get your free
sample box of great tasting healthy
snacks forget the vending machine and
start snacking smarter with delicious
treats like barbeque kettle kernels go
to naturebox.com/tyler box comm slash
Joey thank you to iron dragon tv.com
it's a new roku channel it gives use
code Joey or Church they have two free
rentals they have the it man series and
it's a compatible with the 4k technology
what take know the 4k technology in
January okay